allez on ouvre une page sport à présent
avec le marathon de Tours qui débarque
en ville un parcours 100% urbain dévoilé
aujourd'hui mettant en valeur le
patrimoine local ainsi que les bords de
Loire et du Cher on chausse les baskets
avec l'organisateur de l'événement on
sort Christophe chinette on s'en fout
vous êtes donc président du comité
d'organisation des 10 20 km et du
marathon de Tours c'est du marathon dont
on va parler ce soir la 9e édition c'est
le 24 septembre avec un parcours
entièrement revisité en ville 100%
urbain pour quelle raison
alors tout ça tout simplement parce
qu'il faut se renouveler à un moment
donné c'est comme tout et ça fait
effectivement qu'on disait neuf ans
qu'on fait ce marathon depuis depuis
deux ans on avait un retour à partir du
30e km qui était un peu difficile avec
moins de public et un petit un petit peu
aller qui devenait un peu triste donc il
fallait vraiment le redynamiser et puis
on s'est dit ben pourquoi on se servira
pas de cette belle ville de Tours pour
pour prendre l'ensemble on va dire de la
ville et en faire se servir des lieux
des sites qui sont déjà courus par les
amateurs tous les tous les week-ends et
on a une belle ville donc on va en
profiter et puis c'est surtout pour
retrouver du public du monde de
l'ambiance et un marathon urbain ça
fonctionne aujourd'hui vous avez deux
types de marathons qui fonctionnent bien
c'est tout ce qui est festif c'est tout
ce qui est festif vous avez le Médoc le
Beaujolais voilà tout ça c'est ça
fonctionne bien et puis tout ce qui est
urbain avec des grands marathons qui
fonctionne bien qui sont en centre-ville
voilà donc mais c'est Robin on avait
beaucoup de nature puisque vous savez
que c'est les trahis aujourd'hui aussi
qui fonctionne bien tout ce qui est
nature donc on n'oublie pas et on a une
ville aussi on a la chance d'avoir une
ville très verte avec des bordels les
bords de Loire les bords du Cher
effectivement ils vont profiter tout ça
et puis voilà c'est l'air quoi est-ce
qu'il y a la possibilité d'avoir des
chronos cette année alors il y a
toujours possibilité si on s'entraîne
bien d'avoir des chronos mais attention
et ce marathon il va être exigeant
puisque beaucoup de relance évidemment
qui dit urbains ont dit beaucoup de
relance quelques petites montées aussi
pour ceux qui croient que tours ça monte
pas il y a quelques petites montées mais
il va être superbe avec un très beau
patrimoine alors justement quels sont
les points importants de ce tracé le
point important on passe devant tous les
lieux mythiques de la ville de Tours
donc la les Champs-Élysées tour en jaune
l'avenue Grammont on passe devant le
Palais des Sports on revient à
l'histoire donc au lieu de du sport tout
en jour sur la place Jean Jaurès quand
on a la chance d'avoir un beau temps
hôtel de ville au tribunal devant le
Grand Théâtre donc voilà donc on met
toujours pareil la culture le patrimoine
et le sport voilà donc ça c'est
important aussi pour les coureurs
d'avoir ce public et puis ce patrimoine
aussi un endroit agréable pour courir
alors oui c'est important et puis alors
ça ça devient important on sait que à
partir du 25 30 30 km dans le fameux mur
donc c'est important de revoir du monde
sa famille et ses amis et puis vous
allez voir sur le sur le sur le parcours
la dernière boucle des 10 c'est elle est
commune aussi odyssée 20 km donc il y
aura beaucoup de public pour applaudir
les coureurs du 10 et 20 km et puis ils
seront là pour évidemment accueillir les
coureurs encouragés les coureurs du
marathon comme un coin vous espérez
cette année alors sur le marathon on
espère doubler donc avoir entre 2000 et
2500 marathoniens au total on est quand
même sur une épreuve de 11000 coureurs
entre le 10 le 20 la marche nordique et
puis la course des jeunes et un marathon
qu'on peut faire à deux ça c'est
intéressant du haut effectivement avec
une zone du haut qui qui se qui le duo
va se passer le relais au niveau de
l'île Balzac et la grande différence
avec les autres années c'est que on vous
réserve aussi une zone où le premier
coureur pourra rejoindre le deuxième pas
loin de l'arrivée et puis terminer la
course le marathon ensemble et ça
symboliquement c'est fort et de la
convivialité pour terminer vous
recherchez toujours des bénévoles c'est
crucial pour la bonne tenue de ce
marathon alors oui c'est crucial alors
je je pense aussi toujours c'est une
course éco-responsable donc n'hésitez
pas à aller voir son autre site aussi
tout ce qu'on fait sur les cours
responsabilités ça on y tient et puis
oui des bénévoles il va nous falloir
plus de 1000 bénévoles 500 signes à
l'heure donc c'est pas de mince affaire
il faut que le territoire on a une belle
métropole une belle ville une belle
région beau département il faut que le
territoire crois en lui et il faut qu'on
reste dans les grandes courses
françaises et tout ça grâce à mon
bénévoles donc là à partir de début
avril effectivement on va lancer la
campagne de recrutement des pays -bas on
a besoin de voilà on a besoin de de vous
et puis
bénévole@uning Loire valley.com voilà
c'est c'est le mail générique ne vous
inquiétez pas on va communiquer dessus
et puis les postes seront ouverts merci
beaucoup Christophe chinette pour cette
présentation du marathon de Tours merci